[MUSIC]
I am a classic millennial.
I'm highly jaded and
highly optimistic at the same time.
I'm jaded because let's face it,
we're the generation that inherited
all the consequences of bad
decisions from previous generations.
Climate change, wealth inequality,
broken healthcare.
And to me, businesses seem to be
the biggest culprits of these problems.
But I'm also optimistic that
businesses can be a force for good.
And given the size of the private sector,
businesses need to be forces for
good if we want real scale change.
So how do we make businesses do good?
Of course as a millennial I said,
I'm a problem solver.
I'm gifted and special.
I'm going to single handedly
solve this problem.
You're welcome guys.
>> [LAUGH]
>> After college,
I went into investing to understand and
influence how businesses make decisions.
In my job, I came across a lot of
businesses and a lot of bad decisions.
Here's one well known example,
the BP oil spill.
In 2010, BP was facing a delay
in their drilling operations.
Every day of delay cost them $1 million.
Under immense pressure,
they rushed a launch of an oil
rig in the Gulf of Mexico.
The rig exploded.
Causing the largest oil spill in history,
killing 11 people and
damaging our planet in ways we
still don't fully know today.
This was costly for society,
but also costly for BP.
To save $1 million a day,
BP cost it shareholders $100 billion.
I call this nearsightedness.
Focusing so much on what's in front of you
that you're missing the bigger picture.
Let me ask you a question.
Who here is nearsighted?
So you have trouble seeing what's far from
you but you can see clearly what's close.
I am seriously nearsighted and we all
know how dangerous and frustrating it is.
Imagine one day you're outside
without your glasses or
contacts, you're a disaster
waiting to happen.
You might be scanning the ground for
something you might trip on, and suddenly,
a pole hits your face.
Traditional business thinking
is near sighted, focusing so
much on what's in front of you that
you're missing the bigger picture.
With this realization, I searched for
a better way to invest in and
support businesses.
That is putting on a pair of glasses
that would help me see more clearly and
more comprehensively.
Investing with an impact lens.
By impact lens I mean, asking yourself
more questions before you make decisions.
Is this truly the best decision for the
long-term sustainability of the company?
Can I do this in a way that does good or
reduce harm for society?
Just imagine if someone at BP
had asked those questions.
The impact lens is for everyone, not just
impact investors or social entrepreneurs.
It doesn't mean making
bad decisions to do good.
It means making better decisions
to do good and do well.
Your ears better be perking up because
I'm telling you the impact lens can make
you more money.
>> [LAUGH]
>> With every business and
investment decision you have
to evaluate two things.
Opportunities and risks.
The impact lens can help you
see both new opportunities and
new risks you might not be seeing.
I want to tell you two stories
to show you what I mean.
The first story is about opportunities.
John Treharne was a former English squash
player and an entrepreneur looking for
new opportunities.
As an athlete, he noticed that old
gyms in the UK were located in wealthy
metropolitan areas charging high prices.
This made him think.
A low cost gym concept targeting lower
income markets could do a lot of good and
be really successful.
So he wrote a business plan and
then he sought out funding.
But investor after investor rejected him.
It wouldn't work, they said.
If lower income markets were so
attractive, gyms would already be there.
Then one day he found a match.
Bridges, an impact investment fund had
also concluded that low cost gyms would
be an attractive opportunity to deliver
financial returns and societal impact.
Together, Treharne and
Bridges incubated The Gym Group,
a chain of 24/7,
low cost gyms targeted
at lower income markets.
The Gym Group was a massive success.
In 2015, the company IPOed at
a valuation of $380 million,
almost 6 times the original investment.
Private equity funds typically
target two to three times.
Today, the Gym Group has more than
a 130 gyms and 660,000 members.
Now, lot of gym space was already crowded.
No one had thought lower income markets
were an attractive opportunity.
Treharne and Bridges saw this opportunity
because they had their impact lenses on.
So whether you want to start,
run or invest in businesses,
how can you use the impact lens to see
opportunities you might not be seeing?
The impact lens also helps
you see hidden risks.
Paul Polman became the CEO
of Unilever in 2009.
Polman was a strong believer
in doing well by doing good.
With his impact lens on, he saw
opportunities to grow in emerging markets.
He also saw a risk that no one was
talking about, climate change.
Polman thought climate change was
the single biggest threat to Unilever and
no investor had ever asked
him a question about it.
Polman declared, in ten years,
I'm going to double
profitability while cutting
environmental footprint in half.
Becoming more environmentally
sustainable was going to cut costs, and
reduce risks, he said.
People thought he was crazy.
The results,
eight years of positive growth.
Twice the rate of Unilever's competitors.
Total shareholder return of
nearly 300% in that time period.
Returns in profits are up, but even more
importantly, long term risks are down.
Unilever is better prepared for climate
change than any of its competitors.
Now climate change is just one
example of a societal issue,
threatening corporate welfare.
Global poverty, employee skills gaps,
political and social instability.
Nearsighted businesses will say,
these are not my problems.
But if we put our in impact lenses on,
we can see that these issues will
hit businesses before they know it.
Now I'm not saying that every
decision is going to be a win-win.
But win-win situations are out there and
we absolutely have to chase
every single one of them.
John Treharne and Paul Polman
are two pioneers in this movement.
Slowly, others are catching up.
Just last year, the CEO of BlackRock,
Larry Fink said in a statement to CEOs.
To prosper overtime, every business must
not only deliver financial performance but
also show how it makes a positive
contribution to society.
What we need are more business leaders and
institutional investors with
their impact lenses on.
We also need personal investors and
consumers demanding for
more impact from businesses.
We millennials have to take that charge.
We're known as the generation of FOMO,
fear of missing out.
Well guess what?
We're missing out big time because we're
not using the impact lens in our business
thinking.
We're also known as the generation
of self entitlement.
Well, I think we are entitled.
To a better future where businesses
can be part of the solution and
not just the problem.
Where a fresh set of lenses can help
us see the world in a better light.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]